in the conduct of a clinical trial
a sponsor is an individual institution
company or organization that takes the
responsibility to initiate
manage or finance the clinical trial but
does not actually conduct the
investigation
the sponsor should implement a system to
manage quality throughout all stages of
the trial process sponsors should focus
on trial activities essential to
ensuring human subject protection
and the reliability of trial results
quality management includes the design
of efficient clinical trial protocols
and tools and procedures for data
collection and processing
as well as the collection of information
that is essential to decision making
the quality management system should use
a risk-based approach as described below
critical process and data identification
during protocol development the sponsor
should identify those processes and data
that are critical to ensure human
subject protection and the reliability
of trial results
risk identification the sponsor should
identify risks to critical trial
processes
and data risks should be considered at
both the system level
such as standard operating procedures
computerized systems
and personnel and clinical trial level
such as trial design
data collection and informed consent
process
risk evaluation the sponsor should
evaluate the identified risks
against existing risk controls by
considering the likelihood of errors
occurring
the extent to which such errors would be
detectable and the impact of such errors
on human subject protection and
reliability of trial results
risk control the sponsor should decide
which risks to reduce and which risks
to accept the approach used to reduce
risk to an acceptable level should be
proportionate to the significance of the
risk
risk reduction activities may be
incorporated in protocol design
and implementation monitoring plans
agreements between parties defining
roles and responsibilities
systematic safeguards to ensure
adherence to standard operating
procedures
and training in processes and procedures
predefined quality tolerance limits
should be established
taking into consideration the medical
and statistical characteristics of the
variables as well as the statistical
design of the trial
to identify systematic issues that can
impact subject
safety or reliability of trial results
detection of deviations from the
predefined quality tolerance limits
should trigger an evaluation to
determine if action is needed
risk communication the sponsor should
document quality management activities
the sponsor should communicate quality
management activities to those who are
involved in
or affected by such activities to
facilitate risk review
and continual improvement during
clinical trial execution
risk review the sponsor should
periodically review risk control
measures to ascertain whether the
implemented quality management
activities remain effective and relevant
taking into account emerging knowledge
and experience
risk reporting the sponsor should
describe the quality management approach
implemented in the trial and summarize
important deviations from the predefined
quality tolerance limits and remedial
actions taken in the clinical study
report
a sponsor may transfer any or all of the
sponsor's trial related duties and
functions to a cro
but the ultimate responsibility for the
quality and integrity of the trial data
always resides with the sponsor
the cro should implement quality
assurance and quality control
any trial related duty and function that
is transferred to and assumed by a cro
should be specified in writing
any trial related duties and functions
not specifically transferred to when
assumed by a cro are retained by the
sponsor
all references to a sponsor in the gcp
guideline
also apply to a cro to the extent that a
cro has assumed the trial related duties
and functions of a sponsor
the sponsor should designate
appropriately qualified medical
personnel
who will be readily available to advise
on trial related medical questions or
problems
if necessary outside consultants may be
appointed for this purpose
the sponsor should utilize qualified
individuals such as biostatisticians
clinical pharmacologists and physicians
throughout all stages of the trial
process
from designing the protocol and planning
the analyses to analyzing and preparing
interim and final clinical trial reports
the sponsor should utilize appropriately
qualified individuals to supervise the
overall conduct
of the trial to handle the data to
verify the data
to conduct the statistical analyses and
to prepare the trial reports
the sponsor may consider establishing an
independent data monitoring committee
or idmc to assess the progress of a
clinical trial
including the safety data and the
critical efficacy endpoints at intervals
and to recommend to the sponsor whether
to continue
modify or stop a trial
the idmc should have written operating
procedures and maintain written records
of all its meetings
if data are transformed during
processing
it should always be possible to compare
the original data and observations with
the process data
the sponsor should use an unambiguous
subject identification code that allows
identification of all the data reported
for each subject
the sponsor or other owners of the data
should retain all of the sponsor
specific essential documents pertaining
to the trial
the sponsor should retain all sponsor
specific essential documents in
conformance with the applicable
regulatory requirements of the countries
where the product is approved
or where the sponsor intends to apply
for approvals
if the sponsor discontinues the clinical
development of an investigational
product for any or all indications
roots of administration or dosage forms
the sponsor should maintain all sponsor
specific essential documents for at
least two years after formal
discontinuation
or in conformance with the applicable
regulatory requirements
if the sponsor discontinues the clinical
development of an investigational
product
the sponsor should notify all the trial
investigators
and all the regulatory authorities any
transfer of ownership of the data should
be reported to the appropriate
authorities
as required by the applicable regulatory
requirements
the sponsor is responsible for selecting
the investigators or institutions
each investigator should be qualified by
training and experience
and should have adequate resources to
properly conduct the trial
for which the investigator is selected
before entering an agreement with an
investigator to conduct a trial
the sponsor should provide the
investigator with the protocol
and an up-to-date investigators brochure
and should provide sufficient time for
the investigator to review the protocol
and the information provided
allocation of responsibilities prior to
initiating a trial
the sponsor should define establish and
allocate all trial related duties and
functions
the financial aspects of the trial
should be documented in an agreement
between the sponsor
and the investigator or institution the
sponsor should provide
insurance or should indemnify the
investigator and the institution against
claims arising from the trial
except for claims that arise from
malpractice or negligence
the sponsor's policies and procedures
should address the costs of treatment of
trial
subjects in the event of trial related
injuries in accordance with the
applicable regulatory requirements
notification and submission to
regulatory authorities
before initiating the clinical trials
the sponsor should submit any required
applications to the appropriate
authorities for review
acceptance and permission to begin the
trials
any notification or submission should be
dated and contain sufficient information
to identify the protocol
confirmation of review by irb
the sponsor should obtain from the
investigator or institution
the name and address of the
investigators or institutions irb
a statement obtained from the irb that
it is organized and operates according
to gcp
and the applicable laws and regulations
and documented irb approval and a
current copy of protocol written
informed consent forms and any other
written information to be provided to
subjects
subject recruiting procedures and
documents related to payments
and compensation available to the
subjects and any other documents that
the irb
may have requested if the irb conditions
its approval upon changes in any aspect
of the trial
such as modifications of the protocol
written informed consent form and any
other written information to be provided
to subjects
or other procedures the sponsor should
obtain from the investigator a copy of
the modifications made and the date
approval was given by the irb
the sponsor should obtain from the
investigator documentation
and dates of any irb re-approvals and of
any withdrawals or suspensions of
approval
information on investigational products
when planning trials the sponsor should
ensure that sufficient safety and
efficacy data from non-clinical studies
and clinical trials are available to
support human exposure by the root at
the dosages for the duration
and in the trial population to be
studied the sponsor should update the
investigators brochure as significant
new information becomes available
manufacturing packaging labeling and
coding investigational products
the sponsor should ensure that the
investigational products
including active comparators and placebo
are characterized as appropriate to the
stage of development of the products
is manufactured in accordance with any
applicable gmp
and is coded and labeled in a manner
that protects the blinding
in addition the labeling should comply
with applicable regulatory requirements
the sponsor should determine for the
investigational products
acceptable storage temperatures storage
conditions storage times
reconstitution fluids and procedures and
devices for product infusion
the sponsor should inform all involved
parties these determinations
the investigational products should be
packaged to prevent contamination
and unacceptable deterioration during
transport and storage
in blinded trials the coding system for
the investigational products
should include a mechanism that permits
rapid identification of the products in
case of a medical emergency
but does not permit undetectable breaks
of the blinding
if significant formulation changes are
made in the investigational or
comparator products during the course of
clinical development
the results of any additional studies of
the formulated products needed to assess
whether these changes would
significantly alter the pharmacokinetic
profile of the product should be
available prior to the use of the new
formulation in clinical trials
supplying and handling investigational
products
the sponsor is responsible for supplying
the investigator with the
investigational products
the sponsor should not supply an
investigator with the investigational
products until the sponsor obtains all
required documentation
the sponsor should ensure that written
procedures include instructions that the
investigator should follow for the
handling and storage of investigational
products for the trial and documentation
thereof
the procedure should address adequate
and safe receipt handling
storage dispensing retrieval of unused
product from subjects
and return of unused investigational
products to the sponsor
record access the sponsor should ensure
that it is specified in the protocol
or other written agreement that the
investigators provide direct access to
source data or documents for trial
related monitoring
irb review and regulatory inspection
the sponsor should verify that each
subject has consented
in writing to direct access to his or
her original medical records for trial
related monitoring
irb review and regulatory inspection
adverse drug reaction reporting the
sponsor should expedite the reporting to
all concerned investigators
to the irbs and to the regulatory
authorities of all adverse drug
reactions or adrs
that are both serious and unexpected
such expedited reports should comply
with the applicable regulatory
requirements and with the ich guideline
for clinical safety data management
definitions and standards for expedited
reporting
the sponsor should submit to the
regulatory authorities all safety
updates and periodic reports
as required by applicable regulatory
requirements
premature termination or suspension of a
trial
if a trial is prematurely terminated or
suspended
the sponsor should promptly inform the
investigators and the regulatory
authorities of the termination or
suspension
and the reasons for the termination or
the irb should also be informed promptly
and provided the reasons for the
termination or suspension by the sponsor
or by the investigator
as specified by the applicable
regulatory requirements
clinical trial and study reports whether
the trial is completed or prematurely
terminated
the sponsor should ensure that the
clinical trial reports are prepared and
provided to the regulatory agencies as
required by the applicable regulatory
requirements
the sponsor should also ensure that the
clinical trial reports in marketing
applications meet the standards of the
ich guideline for structure and content
of clinical study reports
in summary sponsors are primarily
responsible for selecting investigators
providing them with the information
necessary to conduct a trial
monitoring the investigation ensuring
that it is conducted in accordance with
the general investigational plan
in protocols and informing investigators
or the authorities of any new risks or
adverse effects associated with a drug
you